Você sabia que mais de 60% dos
brasileiros acima dos 50 anos sofrem com
algum tipo de dor articular? E a grande
maioria faz exatamente a mesma coisa.
Toma um antiinflamatório de farmácia,
espera passar e repete o ciclo quando a
dor volta. Um estudo publicado no
European Journal of Clinical Nutrition
em 2025, nesse ano, analisando nove
ensaios clínicos com quase 900
participantes, mostrou que intervenções
dietéticas reduziram a dor em
osteoartrite com uma diferença
padronizada de -067,
um efeito significativo e sustentado.
Enquanto isso, o ibuprofeno que você
toma só mascara o sintoma por algumas
horas. Hoje eu vou te mostrar um
protocolo de 30 dias que ataca a raiz do
problema. A inflamação crônica
silenciosa que está destruindo suas
articulações enquanto você acha que está
tudo bem.
Deixa eu te contar uma coisa que eu vejo
quase todo dia na clínica. Chega o
paciente com dor no joelho, no ombro,
nas mãos e o que que ele já fez? Tomou
de culofenáco, tomou nimesulida, às
vezes até injeção de corticide. A dor
aliviou por um tempo? Sim, aliviou e
voltou? Sempre volta. Sabe por quê?
Porque anti-inflamatório é igual apagar
fogo com extintor. Resolve o incêndio
momentâneo. Mas se você não desligar o
botijão de gás que está vazando, o fogo
volta. E no caso das articulações, esse
botijão vazando é inflamação crônica de
baixo grau que se alimenta do seu estilo
de vida. Uma metaanálise publicada no
Phytotherapy Research em junho de 2024,
que analisou 11 metanálises anteriores
sobre curcumina e osteoartrite,
encontrou resultados impressionantes:
redução significativa na escala de dor
VAS, melhora na função articular medida
pelo índice
e diminuição da rigidez. Estamos falando
de evidência robusta, não de achismo. E
o mais interessante, a cocomina trabalha
por mecanismos diferentes dos
antiinflamatórios convencionais. Ela
modula a resposta inflamatória na
origem, reduzindo citocinas como TNF
alfa, intelecina 1 beta e teleucina 6.
Mas calma, não é só tomar cúrcuma em
cápsula e esperar milagre. A grande
sacada está na combinação sinégérgica.
Um estudo publicado no Journal of
Inflammation em 2025 mostrou que a
combinação de cucumina omega-3 teve
efeitos superiores no modelo de
osteoartrite, diminuiu a dor, conservou
a cartilagem e, mais importante,
melhorou a função mitocondrial das
células articulares. As mitocôndrias são
as usinas de energia das células. Quando
elas funcionam mal, a inflamação dispara
e a regeneração falha. Agora vem o pulo
do gato que poucos conhecem, o magnésio.
Um estudo com dados da Oste Fridays
Iniciative mostrou que baixa ingestão de
magnésio está diretamente associada com
maior dor no joelho em pacientes com
osteoartrite radiográfica e pasm. 68%
dos homens e 44% das mulheres com
osteoartrite consome menos magnésio do
que o necessário. O magnésio não é
apenas um mineral qualquer, ele
participa de mais de 300 reações
enzimáticas no nosso organismo,
incluindo a modulação da resposta
inflamatória. Então, deficiência em
magnésio eleva marcadores inflamatórios
como a proteína C reativa, interleucina
6 e fator de necrósito moral alfa. Então
vamos ao protocolo de 30 dias. Primeira
semana, foco na base alimentar. Você vai
eliminar os alimentos próinflamatórios,
açúcar refinado, óleos vegetais
processados como óleo de soja, milho,
canola, geraassol, farinha branca,
embutidos. Isso não é frescura de
nutricionista, é ciência. A metaanálise
do European Journal of Clinical
Nutrition mostrou que dietas de
restrição energética melhoraram
significativamente a dor com efeito
padronizado de -085
e a função física com -095.
Você vai aumentar vegetais coloridos,
especialmente os verdes escuros, peixes
de água fria, pelo menos três vezes na
semana, azeite de oliva extravirgem e
frutas vermelhas. Um estudo publicado no
Nutrients em 2019 mostrou que o consumo
de 40 g de mirtilo liofilizado por dia
durante 4 meses melhorou dor, rigidez e
dificuldade nas atividades diárias em
pacientes com osteoartrite de joelho.
Segunda e terceira semanas entra a
suplementação estratégica. Curcumina
biodisponível. E aqui é importante
frisar, a curcumina comum tem absorção
péssima. Eu falei isso em live de
algumas semanas atrás e tem um vídeo da
edição da live. Então não perde esse
vídeo, dá uma olhada se você não viu.
Então você precisa de uma fórmula com
piperina ou uma formulação lipossomal na
faixa de 500 a 1000 mg por dia, ou pode
ser até uma quantidade menor se for uma
curcumina de alta absorção. Então
assiste o outro vídeo para ver mais
detalhes sobre isso. Além disso, ômega-3
de qualidade, priorizando EPA e DHA com
dose total de 2 a 3 g por dia. O estudo
Pascod publicado no Journal of
Rheumatology em 2025 mostrou que a
combinação de curcumina, ômega-3 e
vitamina D de dado por apenas 4ro
semanas já foi capaz de reduzir
significativamente a dor articular
autorrelatada em voluntários saudáveis.
Magnésio queelado, preferencialmente na
forma de bisiglicinato malato, entre 300
e 400 mg por dia. E vitamina D3, porque
ela trabalha em sinergia com os outros
componentes, dose ajustada conforme o
seu exame, mas geralmente entre 2.000 a
5.000 unidades por dia. Quarta semana,
aí você faz a consolidação e avaliação.
Nessa fase você já deve perceber
diferença na rigidez matinal, na
facilidade de se movimentar. na
necessidade de analgésicos. Um estudo em
modelo animal publicado no Friday's
Research and Therapy mostrou que a
combinação de curcumina biodisponível
com vitamina D e ômega-3 reduziu a
severidade da artrite em mais de 80% e
atrasou significativamente o início da
doença. Claro que estudo em animal não é
igual a estudo em humano, mas o
mecanismo está lá. Modulação de
citocinas inflamatórias, proteção do
metabolismo da cartilagem, melhora da
resposta imune regulatória. E tem um
erro que quase todo mundo comete e eu
preciso te alertar. A pessoa toma o
suplemento por uma semana, não vê
resultado imediato e quer desistir.
Olha, inflamação crônica não se instalou
em uma semana e não vai embora em uma
semana. O corpo precisa de tempo para se
reequilibrar. Os estudos mostram
resultados consistentes a partir de 4 a
8 semanas de intervenção contínua.
Então, comprometa-se com os 30 dias
completos antes de avaliar. Outro ponto
crucial, não adianta tomar todos os
suplementos do mundo se você continua
sedentário ou sedentária. Um movimento
articular, especialmente exercício de
baixo impacto como caminhada, natação,
bicicleta, é fundamental pra nutrição da
cartilagem. A cartilagem não tem vasos
sanguíneos, ela se nutre pelo líquido
sinovial e esse líquido precisa de
movimento para circular. Sem movimento,
a cilagem literalmente morre de fome. E
olha só uma informação que muita gente
conhece. Existe um ensaio clínico
registrado no clinicaltrials.gov,
o nctando
pacientes para avaliar justamente o
efeito da dieta antiinflamatória na
osteoartrite de joelho. Ou seja, a
ciência está cada vez mais reconhecendo
que o caminho não é só remediar sintoma,
é mudar o terreno onde a doença se
desenvolve. Para você que está pensando,
mas doutor já tenho osteoartrite há
anos? Será que funciona? Deixa eu te dar
uma esperança baseada em ciência. O
estudo com morangos publicado no
Nutrients em 2017 mostrou que mesmo
pacientes obesos com evidência
radiográfica de osteoartrite de joelho
tiveram redução significativa nos
marcadores inflamatórios de Teleucina 6,
intelecina 1 beta e mmp3.
Após 12 semanas de suplementação. A
inflamação é simreversível.
O dano estrutural avançado, lógico, é
mais difícil de reverter, mas a
inflamação que causa dor e progressão da
doença pode ser modulada. Então,
recapitulando o protocolo de 30 dias,
primeira semana, ajuste alimentar,
eliminando pró-inflamatórios,
incluindo alimentos protetores. Segunda
a quarta semanas, adição de curcumina
biodisponível 500 a 1000 mg por dia. O
volume pode ser menor se for de alta
absorção. Ô3 com 2 a 3 g de EPA mais
DHA. Magnésio queelado 300 a 400 mg.
vitamina D ajustada ao seu exame.
Durante todo o período, movimento diário
de baixo impacto, hidratação adequada.
Ao final de 30 dias, avalie. Como é que
está a sua rigidez matinal? Precisa de
menos analgésico, consegue subir escada
com mais facilidade? Esses são os
marcadores reais de que você está
tratando a causa e não apenas apagando o
fogo. Agora saia do vídeo se você gosta
de ficar no superficial, porque eu vou
te contar uma verdade conveniente. O
YouTube e o conselho me limitam a que eu
preciso simplificar censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos sobre dor
articular, inflamação, por exemplo. Não
posso falar abertamente sobre protocolos
de doses mais altas de cocumina que eu
uso em casos refratários ou sobre
combinações específicas com enzimas
proteíticas que aceleram resultados. Na
comunidade fechada não tem esse filtro.
Eu compartilho os exatos protocolos que
eu uso na minha clínica, incluindo o
protocolo completo antiinflamatório com
dosagens precisas, timing de
administração, combinações que
potencializam os resultados em semanas e
casos de reversão de dor crônica que
pareciam impossíveis. Também temos
combinações of label que funcionam,
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames inflamatórios. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários, lives
semanais respondendo perguntas ou PDF
com 47 protocolos exclusivos. O grupo no
WhatsApp com uma equipe maravilhosa. Se
você quer a visão funcional real, sem
simplificação para massas, clique aqui
embaixo, seja membro. E não é para
curiosa, é para quem quer resultados.
Agora, se você quer ainda mais fundo,
existe o nível dois. A cada duas
semanas, nós fazemos live de imersão
total com 2 horas de duração. Nós desse
artigos científicos, linha por linha,
como os últimos estudos sobre
sinalização inflamatória e regeneração
articular que a maioria dos médicos
ainda não conhece, debatendo
controvérsia que ninguém quer tocar e
revelando os bastidores das pesquisas
que a indústria farmacêutica não quer
que você entenda. E tem mais, o seu nome
será mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se tornar parte
visível dessa comunidade de elite que
está reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste,
passivamente, você tá do meu lado
construindo conhecimento de verdade,
tendo o seu reconhecimento público como
alguém que investe no que realmente
importa. E não é só sobre aprender, é
sobre pertencer ao ciclo interno de quem
está mudando o jogo. Poucos têm essa
coragem, você tem? E já que estamos
falando de inflamação e suplementos,
você precisa conhecer as dicas para usar
cúrcum a curcumina corretamente.
Suplemento versus tempero, faz toda a
diferença. Aqui vou mostrar para você um
vídeo, você vai assistir agora em
sequência para complementar
perfeitamente o que você aprendeu hoje.
Agradecimentos especiais aos nossos
queridos membros dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada do YouTube. Karim,
Lurdete, Carlos Roveri, Odonor Pinheiro,
Cíntia de Assis, Adriane BMS, Jorge
Cabral, Marcelo Pimentel, Cláudia
Leitão, Alex Caldas, Ana Paula Vascular,
José Fortunato Murtinho, FS Machado RJ,
Sou Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana
Moraril, Estela Mares, Elô Terapias
Integrativas e Saúde. Muito obrigado
pelo seu apoio.